whoo welcome to this video I'm playing
against a username really thats that's a
name I username okay it's a player from
from Norway this is 85 is quite
interesting line against this opening
has been played quite often by the lid
on grant Muslim white cubic hive yep
it's a possible idea he goes yeah I
plenty form and we get a fairly typical
position for ya for Kings Indian mostly
but um okay it's not playing g6
the only thing that's rather get a
submission 26 you normally don't play
this move early maybe I should have
played 90 form to grab this yeah let's
let's do that I don't I don't want
Bishop e2 95 and you for ice attacked I
don't have a natural way to protect it
so three very slow development
don't like it I like to take on e6 if
you play c6 now ok Bishop e3 coming this
should be ok and out loud and so let's
grab this
getting down the bishop down we take the
pawn bishop III Oh interesting I was
more you know I thought I thought you
would go for d5 yeah this is a
possibility but i don't really know I
don't really think it's it's too great I
have to say three before I diem and I
don't think you get to deform IC IC
intends to do 6i can check a three okay
I need to spend this temple maybe you
can play the very radical move c5 and
then then the 94 but it weakens
everything and the moment c5 that can
just play 25
yeah maybe night f form this is idea not
a bad idea but I have to see if I can
take and place you five then
maybe you can play just 95 phone you can
just play 5c 5 isn't threatening
anything ah this was bad okay i need to
change plans then try to play for rugby
7
yeah it's got an excellent night no
I need to be cautious because of the
dark squares there they are seriously
weakened
c5 the idea it's not really threatening
much but turn it irritated time
I don't really think I'm threatening
something it it looks I'd look so active
but so it's not it's not really a threat
all this
I'm not sure how I how I can improve my
position
maybe now this is maybe Bishop Bishop g3
even possible I can play h3 though try
to reroute the night the shop g3 I play
age three
taking is very risky at least risky
our queen g3 I forgot about that
hmm
wow what the heck
can play rook everyone on Queen g3 can
talk about unnecessary weaknesses Jesus
Wow what that did i do time warning
well
check check check check check black for
fits on time hmm Wow yeah I completely
outplayed myself here this was just bad
yeah okay this position is really not
not not so great for white when I tried
to I tried to do something here damn it
it was just backfiring I mean I was
aware that this age 3 business is risky
but i could buy what i did i completely
forgot that he can do that and this was
very strong done i mean it's it's just
just terrible i flat-out losing the
compass on minus five yes somehow
somehow it wasn't it wasn't a maid
somehow he can take here this is one
improvement but this wasn't bad night c4
again wins check gasps irritated him I
could have taken her okay when I did
they gave me the Queen even he didn't
have any time left so it's a some
understandable that such a blunder yeah
I should have started anything with age
three this was just bad okay thanks for
watching